congregation in Florida joined together
in faith and perseverance even as the
walls of their church collapsed around
them under the fury of Hurricane Michael
25 church members along with their
pastor took shelter in the building when
Michael barreled ashore last week
everyone survived this is what st.
Andrew United Methodist Church looked
like a week before the storm Jericka
Duncan joins us now from Panama City
where the church refused to shut its
doors to those in need
Jericka good morning good morning you
can see that the welcome sign was blown
out there is caution tape all around
this church and when you look at how it
was constructed we're talking layers and
layers of bricks that could not
withstand the strength of that category
4 hurricane
you know yesterday when the pastor held
service outside he told his members that
the church is not the rubble behind us
but it is us it was an emotional service
Sunday held in the shadow of a crumbled
Saint Andrew for many members this
church was like a second home
the church was no match for Hurricane
Michaels fury Pastor John blunt recorded
this video moments after the walls were
ripped away miraculously everyone inside
the damaged church survived including a
91 year old woman who took shelter in a
closet
I know I was praying for life they care
about the buildings or the trees blunts
wife Caroline who had evacuated to
Alabama with their 11 year old daughter
learned about what happened on Facebook
you didn't know if your husband was even
alive now
he called me probably about two hours
after that he just said I'm okay I'm
okay the sanctuary is gone but I'm okay
this is our sanctuary after the storm
pastor Blount walked us through what
hurricane Michael left behind half of
the building is now gone but right in
the center standing on top of a podium
the church Bible appears to have
weathered the storm symbolizes week we
held up well God's Word and doers
despite the damage the church continued
in its work distributing supplies to
those in need like the rest of Panama
st. Andrew plans to rebuild but Blount
says he doesn't need God's house to do
God's work this is just a building it's
gonna get fixed but the people need us
right now so it's really good time for
us to actually be the church st. andrew
has been in this community since 1896
this building though was constructed in
1955 the pastor of the church says that
its members about 300 was definitely
closed before this storm hit he says now
they're even closer as you can imagine
everyone just leaning on each other Gail
all right Jericka thank you very much
pictures really tell the story there
thank you